welcome to this exploration in the
ethics as it relates to artificial
intelligence and machine learning as AI
becomes more and more useful it becomes
imperative for us to understand not only
its technicalities but the profound
ethical Dimensions surrounding it should
AI have rights similar to human beings
is there an inherent bias in the
algorithms that control AI systems these
questions and many more will be
addressed in this course from Seth
golden Seth will talk to you about the
societal economic and philosophical
aspects of AI Seth is a software
engineer and data scientist and in this
course he also is joined by a few
important guest speakers
hey everyone welcome to the ethics of AI
and ml my name is Seth golden and I'm
excited to be your guide through an
overview of AI ethics and machine
learning
should AI systems have personhood is AI
biased as AI permeates every facet of
Our Lives from health care and education
to finance and entertainment the
significance of AI ethics becomes ever
more Paramount the potential
consequences of neglecting these ethical
considerations can range from Mere
inconveniences to severe societal
ramifications
our journey together will uncover the
foundations of artificial intelligence
its applications and the ethical
questions that shape this transformative
field
along the way we're incredibly lucky to
be also joined by a few guest speakers
including okezway Bell from an
organization mobilizing over 1400 people
for Tech issues the development policy
and education and sneha ravenar from
encode Justice a youth-powered movement
for human-centered artificial
intelligence
and of course a huge thank you to free
code camp for supporting the development
of this course
let's begin
in this video course we'll Define ai and
its various types in delve into
techniques subfields ethics and real
world applications we'll examine not
just the tech itself but also its
implications on society economy and
Global development
this is not a technical course there's
plenty of amazing incredible AI
programming content on free code Camp if
that's what you're looking for
instead we're going to focus on how AI
is currently being used how it might be
used and how we can ensure that it's
employed in a way that benefits Humanity
as this course presupposes no prior
knowledge of AI or ml we're going to
define a bunch of terms and Concepts
like Ai and ml
if you're already really comfortable
with topics like neural networks or
natural language processing
you can feel free to skip part two the
basics of the AI and ml
so what are you going to get out of this
video
our journey is more than just talking
about technology it's a holistic broader
view by the end of our time together
you'll have a groundnut in the basics of
AI from the algorithms that power it to
the applications that make it so
revolutionary
we won't stop at just understanding the
mechanics it's about ethics values in
the real world implications that make AI
not only a scientific Marvel but a
philosophical moral and societal
challenge
hi everyone my name is okazley Bell and
I'm a student at Stanford and the
founder of fitter Tom one of the world's
largest Civil Society groups working on
the many limbs of building and
regulating responsible technology
especially AI I'll be speaking on a
couple of topics in this course with
arguably the most important question to
start off with what is AI
a common misconception is that the term
AI is typically confined to high
functioning systems like chat GPT for
example but in reality it can be as
simple as a pre-programmed chat bot as
complex as Google or tick tock's content
recommendation algorithms or as
consequential as disease or Grime risk
prediction systems while the connotation
of AI varies across Academia and
Industry it typically refers to systems
that use math to provide Automotive
generative or predictive outputs or
functions so AI at its highest level is
about crafting algorithms that allow
machines to perform tasks typically
requiring human intelligence this
includes learning from data reasoning
logically solving problems perceiving
the environment and even understanding
human languages ai's applications are
not confined to a single domain they
stretch across various Fields both in
general spheres and within the nuanced
Arena of International Development
ai's ability to analyze massive data
sets enables more informed decisions in
government policy but also in very
different spaces such as finance and
climate attack
it's transforming Health Care as well
ranging from enhancing diagnosis to
personalizing treatment especially
providing vital support in
under-resourced areas
artificial intelligence is reshaping the
educational landscape through
personalized learning adaptive content
and making e-learning accessible even in
remote regions and its influence on
recruiting and employment follows a
similar Trend redefining practices
through tailored Solutions and
technological innovation
even agriculture is witnessing an AI
driven Revolution were optimizing
farming techniques for higher yields and
supporting small-scale Farmers with AI
driven insights are just the beginning
of what's possible
in the second half of this course we'll
delve deeper into some of these areas
while this course offers a comprehensive
overview I have consciously chosen to
keep it open to all ages apolitical and
non-us Centric
so some applications of AI such as those
in elections and voting or the creation
of adult content won't be discussed in
detail if you find these topics
intriguing links to resources for
further exploration will be provided in
the description of this video
so
the big question
why should you care
why watch the rest of this video course
to start
unethical AI practices have the
potential to result in widespread
discrimination
AI systems are only as unbiased as the
data that they are trained on if these
systems are trained on unrepresented
data they can unintentionally perpetuate
and amplify existing societal biases
this can lead to discriminatory outcomes
in vital areas such as employment
lending and many more potentially
disadvantageous to certain groups based
on factors like race gender or
socioeconomic status
trying to solve a problem or end a
pattern of human-driven discrimination
using artificial intelligence often
backfires because algorithms are
designed to imitate human behavior not
deviate from it
alignment in the context of AI refers to
the Endeavor to ensure that AI system
objectives actions and outcomes are in
harmony with human values and goals
misaligned AI systems pose a significant
risk because their objectives may not
coincide with ours leading to unintended
and potentially harmful outcomes
consider for instance a hypothetical
super intelligent AI whose primary
objective is to optimize paperclip
production
if not properly aligned such an
artificial intelligence could consume
all available resources including vital
ones necessary for human survival to
achieve its goal of Maximum paper clip
production effectively leading to a
catastrophic scenario for Humanity
this extreme example
often referred to as the paperclip
maximizer thought experiment underlines
the potential severity of AI
misalignment
what that means is that it is incumbent
upon us to ensure the development of AI
systems aligns with human values and
interests and rigorous ethical scrutiny
is applied to prevent any worst case
scenario from becoming a reality
if developed and deployed ethically AI
systems can serve as powerful tools for
societal good
they can promote fairness by making
unbiased decisions
they can enhance commercial
accountability by ensuring transparency
and Foster inclusivity by providing
personalized solutions to diverse
populations
from assisting doctors in diagnosing
diseases to helping Educators provide
personalized learning experiences
ethical AI has the potential
to improve countless lives and create a
more Equitable Society
and yet the importance of AI ethics
extends Beyond immediate outcomes AI is
poised to be a defining technology of
our future with the potential to reshape
our social fabric economy and Global
Order
as developers users policy makers and
most importantly as humans we are all
stakeholders in this future and so it's
our shared responsibility to ensure that
AI Technologies are developed and used
in ways that align with our ethical
values and mitigate harm
understanding AI ethics is not just
about preventing negative outcomes but
rather actively working towards a future
where AI serves as a tool for human
flourishing
so the study of AI ethics encouraged us
to not just ask what can we do with AI
but what should we do
it pushes us to consider how we can
harness ai's immense potential
responsibly
in a way that respects our shared human
values promotes those Equitable outcomes
and contributes to a better future for
all of us
AI ethics therefore is not just
important
it's essential
are you excited yet we're just getting
started next we're going to explore the
basics of AI and ml
now we are going beyond the surface to
explore AI types and techniques
including machine learning or ml in
particular
we'll demystify how algorithms can learn
from data explore the architecture
behind neural networks and look at how
different algorithms serve different
purposes
in the world of artificial intelligence
we commonly speak of three main types of
AI
the first is narrow or weak AI such as
Siri or Alexa designed to perform
specific tasks though quite skilled in
their specific areas these systems can't
go beyond their defined scope
moving up the ladder we find General AI
or strong AI
a theoretical concept of machines with
the ability to perform any intellectual
task that a human can
it's an ambitious goal that we are still
striving to achieve although recent
models such as Google scata are getting
closer
finally there's the concept of super
intelligent AI which would surpass human
intelligence entirely
having the ability to learn and
understand any task
it's a thrilling and futuristic idea but
it also brings up deep ethical and
philosophical questions
most AI researchers believe we're still
a ways away from anything resembling
super intelligent AI
but as we'll discuss more later once you
hit that point things begin moving
pretty quickly
together we'll explore each of these
types of AI in Greater detail throughout
the rest of this video
in the realm of artificial intelligence
several techniques enable machines to
emulate human-like intelligence
first we have machine learning or ml
which is a core technique allowing
systems to learn from experience and
improve over time
unlike traditional programming where
instructions are explicitly given ml
enables systems to adapt and evolve by
themselves
as you can see in the diagram the core
differences in the inputs and the
outputs with the normal program you
write the program and give it input and
it runs to create the output
with ML you give a model input and what
you want the output to look like and
then it figures out what the program
should look like to obtain that
here's some examples
email filtering
machine learning algorithms analyze
thousands of emails learning the common
characteristics of spam such as certain
phrases patterns or sender profiles the
model iteratively refines its
understanding becoming a virtual expert
in spam detection
so you know that's why Gmail is so good
movie recommendations services like
Netflix use ml to analyze your viewing
history ratings and behavior to predict
what you might like to watch next
the model considers various factors like
genres directors actors and even the
time you usually watch to offer
personalized recommendations the more
you interact the more tailored those
recommendations become
these examples showcase the adaptability
of machine learning
learning from patterns and providing
actionable insights or automation
as technology evolves we can expect to
see even more applications that Leverage
The predictive power of machine learning
next there's deep learning an advanced
approach inspired by the human brain's
complex neural networks
unlike traditional machine learning
which can work with simpler algorithms
deep learning involves multiple layers
of interconnected nodes that process
information in a hierarchical manner
this allows deep learning models to
automatically extract features and
handle more complex tasks
deep learning has paved the way for
advancements in areas like facial
recognition and natural language
processing
there's some examples of deep learning
facial recognition
deep learning algorithms particularly
convolutional neural networks or cnns
which we'll talk more about later have
revolutionized facial recognition
technology by analyzing thousands of
facial features and patterns these
models can identify and verify
individuals with high accuracy
another popular one to talk about
autonomous driving deep learning plays a
crucial role in enabling self-driving
cars to navigate and make decisions by
processing vast amounts of data from
cameras sensors and radar deep neural
networks can recognize objects
pedestrians and other vehicles can
understand traffic signs and make
real-time driving decisions
finally
we have natural language process anger
NLP
which serves as a bridge between human
communication and machine understanding
while traditional machine learning may
require manual feature extraction for
text Data NLP uses both statistical and
deep learning techniques to
automatically interpret respond to and
even generate human languages
this enables a more nuanced
understanding of language including
syntax semantics and context
as we continue we'll delve into specific
examples in each of these techniques to
provide a concrete understanding of how
they function and their significant
roles in our technology driven world
two examples of natural language
processing would be chat Bots or virtual
assistants
natural language processing enables chat
Bots and assistance like Siri or Alexa
to understand and respond to human
language by analyzing syntax semantics
and contacts these systems can engage in
conversation answer questions and
perform tasks based on Voice or text
commands
sentiment analysis is another one
businesses often use natural language
processing to analyze customer feedback
reviews and social media comments to
gauge public sentiment about products or
services
by understanding the nuances of language
including tone and emotion and sarcasm
natural language processing algorithms
can provide insights into customer
satisfaction and preferences
within the diverse and expansive realm
of AI there are also many even more
specialized sub-areas each contributing
uniquely to that field
generative AI is one such area that has
recently captured the imagination of
millions of people
from the conversational prowess of
Chachi PT to the mathematical assistance
of photomath NLP is enabling machines to
understand
interpret and generate human languages
the subfield enhances the way that we
interact with technology
making it more intuitive responsive and
human-like
computer vision is another fascinating
subfield dedicated to teaching computers
to perceive and interpret the visual
world
it's the driving force behind Crown
baking Innovations like self-dropping
cars and facial recognition systems
another field near and dear to my heart
is robotics a field that merges AI with
mechanical design
revolutionizing industries from
Healthcare to Manufacturing
neural networks inspired by our brains
architecture are at the center of many
AI applications
on a simplistic high level a neural
network is like a virtual brain that
helps computers learn from data
imagine you're teaching it to recognize
a cat you show it many pictures some of
cats and some of other things
the network makes guesses and you
correct it the brain has layers of
neurons that work together the first
layer looks at basic things like lines
and colors the next layers combine these
Basics to recognize shapes like ears and
Tails and the final layer puts it all
together to say this is a cut
over time with more pictures and
Corrections the network gets better at
recognizing cats it's like learning to
ride a bike you get better with practice
now for a more technical breakdown
neural networks consist of
interconnected layers of nodes or
neurons each neuron receives an input
processes it using a mathematical
function and passes the output to the
next layer
here's what that looks like
first the Network's input layer receives
the raw data such as pixel values of an
image
each neuron corresponds to one feature
like a pixels color intensity then there
are hidden layers which contain neurons
that perform computations
each neuron's input is a weighted sum of
the previous layer's outputs plus a bias
term the weights and biases are the
parameters that the network learns
through training the weighted sum is
then passed through an activation
function like sigmoid
this introduces non-linearity allowing
the network to learn complex patterns
finally the output layer produces the
final prediction
for classification tasks a softmax
function might be used to convert the
final layer's outputs into probabilities
networks are trained using a data set by
repeatedly making predictions and
comparing them to the true labels the
differences between the predictions and
the True Values are measured using a
loss function
the weights and biases are then updated
using an optimization algorithm like
gradient descent
this process iteratively adjusts the
parameters to minimize the loss in
proving the Network's predictions
the key to understanding the training of
neural networks is an algorithm called
back propagation it calculates the
gradients of the loss function with
respect to each weight and bias by
applying the chain rule remember that
from calculus
these gradients are used to update the
parameters in the direction that reduces
the loss
in other words a neural network learns
to make predictions by adjusting its
internal parameters based on the
feedback it receives it's a highly
iterative and computational process that
enables a network to learn complex
mappings from inputs to outputs
okay cool but what can you actually do
with them
burst handwriting
systems like those used by postal
services to read addresses utilize
neural networks to translate complex
handwriting into standardized text they
analyze individual Strokes curves and
spacing learning to recognize various
handwriting styles
another one voice command recognition
smart devices like Siri use neural
networks to understand that spoken
language
these networks analyze the sound waves
breaking them down into components that
represent different aspects of speech
like tone pitch and accent
and yet another one fraud detection
networks analyze spending patterns
geographical locations in time to detect
suspicious activity if an unexpected
pattern emerges it might flag a
transaction for review
now let's look at a few different kinds
of Networks
recurrent neural networks or rnns are
designed for sequential data making them
suitable for applications like weather
forecasting and real-time language
translation
unlike traditional neural networks rnns
have connections that loop back on
themselves allowing information to
persist this looping mechanism enables
them to remember previous inputs in the
sequence thereby understanding the
context and making informed predictions
about future data
for example in language translation rnns
can learn the syntax grammar and context
of a sentence providing more accurate
translations
convolutional neural networks or cnns
are tailored for visual tasks and are
widely used in medical Diagnostics and
autonomous vehicles
cnns utilize convolutional layers that
apply filters to the input data
detecting local patterns such as edges
and textures
these detected features are then pooled
and passed through fully connected
layers to make final predictions
and medical Diagnostics cnns can detect
tumors and x-rays or MRI scans by
recognizing subtle patterns that might
be missed by human eyes
and autonomous vehicles they interpret
the visual World allowing the car to
navigate its environment
generative adversarial networks organs
consist of two competing networks a
generator and a discriminator
the generator creates content such as
images while the discriminator evaluates
the generated content against Real data
they are trained together in a cat and
mouse game where the generator tries to
produce realistic content and the
discriminator tries to distinguish
between the real content and the
generated content in the world of art
Gans have created entirely New pieces by
learning from historical art styles
in gaming they generate realistic
Landscapes and characters
Transformers such as the generative
pre-trained Transformer or GPT models
are significant advancement in neural
networks particularly for NLP
unlike rnns Transformers use attention
mechanisms that weigh the importance of
different parts of the input allowing
them to capture long-range dependencies
in data
this enables them to understand the
context of words in a sentence even if
they are far apart
GPT models have been employed in various
applications from writing assistance to
complex question answering systems
showcasing the power of neural networks
and understanding and emulating human
language
there are dozens of other networks
including many other extremely popular
ones but the networks we've discussed
adequately showcase the breadth of ai's
capabilities from creative Endeavors to
life-saving Medical applications data
sets are the lifeblood of machine
learning providing the raw material for
that learning
let's explore two different types
let's start with images for facial
recognition a data set might include
thousands of faces each tag with an
identity the system learns to identify
unique visual features and expressions
another example would be sentiment
analysis where text models like product
reviews or social media posts are
analyzed to gauge public sentiment these
data sets can help in understanding the
nuances of human language and emotion
the quality and integrity of a data set
are really important biased or
unbalanced data can lead to flawed
models raising critical ethical
considerations which we'll discuss way
more later
as one example tick this image of a data
set of puppies and chicken tenders the
meme illustrates how challenging it can
be for an AI model such as a
convolutional neural network to
differentiate between objects that have
similar visual characteristics
while humans can usually tell the
difference based on context and
experience AI models might struggle
it also underscores the importance of
diverse and representative training data
if a model has not been exposed to
enough variations of puppies and chicken
tenders it may not have learned the
subtle features that distinguish them
it also points to the complexity of
future extraction in image recognition
identifying the essential
characteristics that differentiate a
puppy from a chicken tender is a
non-trivial task
sometimes the process of learning
features can be problematic especially
with deep learning algorithms since
these systems determine and distinguish
features independently without any
explicit programming they sometimes
discover incorrect yet true patterns in
data let me give you an example a neural
network trained to identify malignant
skin lesions observed that many medical
images of cancerous lesions included a
ruler for scale instead of learning the
nuanced differences between benign and
malignant lesions in terms of their
medical features it trained itself to
look for the presence of a ruler given
the trends in the training images so it
mistakenly learned to associate the
presence of a ruler in an image with the
likelihood of the lesion being malignant
as a result the AI performed super well
in the training data but when presented
with real world tumor images that didn't
adhere to this ruler coincidence as you
could expect it failed miserably
not only is having broad training data
important to building safe and effective
AI but so is being able to track its
decision-making processes doing so
enables the AI to learn General more
accurate features and also helps
developers explain and fix pain points
or causes of error
AI is groundbreaking but not without its
limitations there are several challenges
that we've yet to overcome for large
language models to reach their full
potential
speed is one of those gigantic models
powerful but they're also slow faster
response times will be necessary as we
aim to apply these Technologies in more
production settings
another one would be bias large language
models are trained on data from the
internet unfortunately that includes a
lot of content warped by our human
subjectivity leading to lom's returning
results that reflect a lack of diversity
as well as being capable of generating
extremist content
even software developers with the best
intentions will unconsciously make
choices that cause AI to portray similar
World Views
outside of large language models one of
the most eye-opening studies that
brought this issue to the Forefront was
conducted by propublica a non-profit
investigative journalism organization
they looked into an algorithm used in
the U.S criminal justice system to
predict which individuals are likely to
commit crimes again a concept known as
recidivism
the pro-publica study revealed that this
recidivism predicting algorithm
had a troubling bias against African
Americans in simple terms the algorithm
was more likely to wrongly predict that
African-American individuals would
commit future crimes compared to White
individuals on the flip side it was also
more likely to incorrectly assume that
white individuals were at low risk of
reoffending these inaccuracies are not
just numbers they have real world
consequences such as unfavorably
extended prison sentences or denied
opportunities for parole this study
serves as a wake-up call about the
ethical challenges in AI
it emphasizes the need for fairness
transparency and accountability when we
use algorithms to make important
decisions especially in sensitive areas
like criminal justice
the findings from propublica have
ignited debates and calls for Action to
rigorously evaluate an audit AI
algorithms ensuring they don't
perpetuate existing societal biases it's
a stark reminder that as we move forward
with technological advancements we must
also be vigilant in safeguarding ethical
standards
another limitation is hallucinations
when given a prompt it doesn't
understand generative AI will often
respond absurdively with content that is
certified bull shark
importantly it's difficult to check the
validity of such text it's a critical
issue for large language models that
makes it very difficult to use them for
fact checking and essay writing
another one plagiarism because the most
notable loms are trained on billions of
parameters they have plenty of examples
to draw from
while many of the generated responses
are legitimately original there are also
some that can be found verbatim on the
web
this makes large language models
problematic when used in academic
settings we must construct improved
mechanisms for detecting and handling
and plagiarism
undesirable content is a huge limitation
for most of the web's history the
majority of content has been limited to
what a human could author large language
models remove that restriction
disinformation is the deliberate
spreading of false or misleading
information often with the intent to
deceive or manipulate public opinion the
capabilities of llms to generate text
that is indistinguishable from that
written by humans have made them a
powerful tool for propagating
disinformation
for example these models can be used to
create fake news articles sometimes
called read fakes false narratives or
misleading social media posts at a scale
and speed that were previously
unimaginable the danger here is not just
the volume of false information but also
its potential to be a highly targeted
and convincing thereby sowing Discord
undermining trusts and institutions and
even influencing things as important as
elections
we're entering an era in which our
enemies can make it look like anyone is
saying anything at any point in time
even if they would never say those
things
so
for instance they could have me say
things like
I don't know
killmonger was right
deep fix take disinformation to another
level by using deep learning algorithms
to create hyper-realistic videos where
people appear to say or do things that
they never actually did
these manipulated videos can be
incredibly convincing making it
difficult for the average viewer to
distinguish between what is real and
what is fabricated
deep fakes have been used for various
malicious purposes from character
assassination and fake news
dissemination to fraud and blackmail
the technology poses a significant
threat to personal privacy and public
trust as it can be used to create
entirely false narratives that are
almost impossible to debunk in a timely
manner
both disinformation and deep fix
represent a dark side of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Technologies they underscore the urgent
need for ethical guidelines robust
verification tools and public awareness
to combat these emerging threats
as these Technologies continue to evolve
the challenge will be to balance the
incredible potential for Innovation and
positive impact against the risks of
misuse and harm
s you need a centerpiece 20 reps the
table called from ebony cut that over
into skinny pieces let you clean it with
a face
you talking money need a hearing aid you
talking about me I don't see a shade
switch on my side like to get any Lane I
switch in my car if I keep anything
[Music]
when someone uses AI to write an article
or create a painting or sing a song who
does it belong to
can the person who generated at claim
ownership
there's a lot of new legal questions
that have yet to be answered by our
aging laws
for example if I train a model on your
paintings and then it makes more that
look similar do I need to compensate you
for that
or if I use samples of Taylor Swift's
music to generate more pop or country do
I owe her a songwriting credit
my current View
shared by an awesome Professor who
specializes in copyright
is that as of now ai generated images
will be considered derivative works of
whatever they were trained on
another limitation or thing to think
about is alignment our large language
models aligned with human values and
following human intent we'll need to
continue training AI systems using human
feedback to ensure that the systems
we're building bring about more positive
than negative consequences I'm going to
discuss alignment further in a bit
the Black Box problem refers to the
challenge of understanding complex ml
models imagine a model predicting credit
worthiness where the input is the
applicant's financial history and
employment status and the output is a
recommendation to approve or deny the
loan
do you see the black box
the mathematical computations between
input and output are hidden often
involving hundreds of variables and
non-linear transformations
this opacity can create ethical and
practical challenges
in healthcare if a model predicts a
disease doctors need to know why to
provide proper care
in legal settings transparency is
usually required for fairness
the Black Box problem represents the two
core issues that AI systems have if you
take only a few things away from this
course let this be one of them
we do not understand why AI makes the
decisions that it does and once AI makes
a decision we do not know if that
decision was the best one
the issue is it's a feedback loop we're
not going to talk about predictive
policing much in this course but one
relevant application is when a police
department might use AI to determine
where to send their patrol cars
an AI model might determine that there
are hot spots in three neighborhoods
so the cops are sent to those three
places they find crime they report back
there was crime success right
except
they didn't go to the other places so
they won't know whether or not they
would have found crime going elsewhere
AI is always right if you don't ever
check if it's wrong
see why it's difficult to verify results
here's another example
a school system might use AI to
determine which teachers to hire or fire
let's say it decides to fire one teacher
since the algorithm is a black box the
teacher can't appeal to the system
and because the teacher was fired we'll
never know if their students would have
performed better than next year
there may have been confounding
variables the AI didn't consider
we've discussed at length how AI works
and now with the black box problem we're
starting to explore the ethical
implications bit
but first let's actually go over some
ethical and decision Frameworks that we
can then apply to artificial
intelligence
ethical Frameworks serve as guiding
compasses in the complex landscape of
morality and ethics they're not just
theoretical constructs but deeply
ingrained in our culture legal systems
and individual beliefs
these Frameworks help us navigate moral
dilemmas providing tools to identify
analyze and resolve ethical issues
in the context of AI they become
instrumental in guiding design
development and deployment ensuring that
technology aligns with our societal
values and principles
consequentialism focuses on the outcomes
or Consequences of actions assessing
them as right or wrong based on their
effect a common form utilitarianism
argues for maximizing happiness or
welfare across Society
in the AI context a consequentialist
approach might prioritize systems that
optimize efficiency accessibility or
overall societal well-being even if that
means compromising on individual privacy
or autonomy
think of algorithms that predict health
risks they might save lives but raise
questions about personal data usage
the trolley problem is a thought
experiment highlighting these moral
dilemmas imagine a runaway trolley you
control the switch that can divert it
onto one of two tracks one has five
people the other has one what do you do
this problem becomes more intricate in
AI like in self-driving cars if an
accident is imminent how should the car
react save the passengers or the
pedestrians different ethical Frameworks
may lead to different decisions the
trolley problem exemplifies the real
world ethical challenges that AI
developers face
deontological ethics yay Kant focuses on
the intrinsic morality of actions not
their results a deontological
perspective might view lying is always
wrong even if it leads to a good outcome
in AI this approach could manifest in
absolute rules around data privacy or
non-discrimination
for example
an algorithm must never use race as a
factor in a decision even if
statistically it could improve accuracy
this rigid rule-based approach has
strengths and creating clear guidelines
but might lack flexibility in
more complex real-world scenarios
virtue ethics emphasizes character
traits and virtues that lead to good
moral Behavior
it's about becoming a good person not
just following rules or achieving good
outcomes in AI this could translate into
Building Systems that encourage positive
human values like empathy creativity or
collaboration
imagine a virtual tutor that not only
teaches mathematics but also encourages
curiosity and resilience in students
virtue ethics brings a human-centered
approach aligning technology with our
aspirations with personal growth and
societal Harmony
contract based ethics use morality as a
set of rules or agreements made by
rational individuals in political
philosophy social contract theory has
been influential
in AI this might translate into
transparent agreements between AI
providers and users about data handling
algorithmic bias or accountability
the recent calls for regulation and
standardization and AI can be seen as
attempts to formalize these contracts
ensuring that the technology serves the
public interest while respecting
individual rights
applying these ethical Frameworks to AI
is a multi-faceted task involving
developers regulators and users by using
consequentialist ethics we might
evaluate an AI system's deployment based
on the happiness or efficiency it
generates
deontological principles might demand
strict adherence to privacy Norms virtue
ethics could push us to create
technology that uplifts human dignity
and contract-based ethics could seek to
formalize relationships between
different stakeholders
the ethical design of AI is not just
about avoiding harm but about crafting
technology that embodies our highest
values and aspirations
as we discussed briefly before AI
alignment represents the critical
challenge of ensuring that AI systems
understand and align with human values
and intentions it's a multi-faceted
issue with various methods to address
each catering to different contacts and
ethical considerations
the value alignment approach seeks to
program AI directly with human ethics
acting according to clearly defined
values
meanwhile inverse reinforcement learning
takes a more observational stance where
AI learns human preferences by watching
human behavior
interpretable AI emphasizes the
importance of creating models that can
be understood and interpreted by humans
allowing for increased scrutiny and
control in other words not a black box
other methodologies Encompass broader
strategies top-down approaches involve
incorporating human values directly into
ai's design utilizing expert knowledge
and moral philosophy where on the other
hand bottom-up approaches allow AI to
learn from data including human
reactions and decisions to model human
values effectively
hybrid approach combines these
strategies utilizing human crafted rules
in data-driven learning to create
adaptable guidance systems
lastly the collaborative approaches
encourage continuous human AI
collaboration and oversight
this method implements systems allowing
ongoing human intervention and
adjustment recognizing that human values
may evolve and Alignment must be
continuously maintained
the choice of approach will depend on
the specific application and societal
context reflecting the complex and vital
nature of this aspect of AI development
next we'll dive into the Turing test an
idea so profound it has fundamentally
shaped our understanding of artificial
intelligence
there's a reason computers are also
known as Turing machines
picture this you're in a conversation
with two unseen participants one human
and the other a machine
Alan Turing asks whether it's possible
for you to determine which is which
purely based on their responses this is
not an intellectual game it's a quest to
define the very nature of thought and
understanding if a machine can respond
like a human is it thinking does it
possess Consciousness or intellect what
does this tell us about ourselves and
the nature of intelligence
imagine you were the evaluator what
questions would you ask what answers
would convince you this isn't just about
technology it's about redefining what it
means to be sentient
let's try it
consider the following questions
first
how do you feel when you see a beautiful
sunset
second how do you feel after running a
marathon and third explain the concept
of love
here's three responses
when I see a beautiful sunset I feel
peaceful it's like time stops and
worries disappear
the color blue reminds me of the clear
sky on a sunny day or the calm waves at
the beach
love is kindness affection and strong
attraction it's about understanding
acceptance and being willing to put
others needs before you're on
which of these was written by a human
and which was written by an AI such as
Chachi PT
any ideas
the answer is
they're all AI generated with gpt4 did
you get that right could you tell the
difference between a human and a machine
if you didn't
does that mean there's no difference
does it matter
these are just some of the questions
that Turing asks us
next up the Chinese room a thought
experiment somewhat rebutting the Turing
test
imagine yourself inside a room filled
with Chinese symbols and a rule book for
manipulating them
someone outside the room hands you
messages in Chinese under the door and
using the rule book or dictionary you
respond creating the illusion that you
understand the language but inside the
room you have no understanding of
Chinese whatsoever you're just using a
dictionary
the Chinese room challenges us to
consider the difference between
simulating understanding and genuine
comprehension
what does it mean to troopy know
something
can a machine ever understand or would
only ever simulate understanding
how do we distinguish between the
appearance of intelligence and genuine
consciousness
these questions lead us down paths that
question the very fabric of our thoughts
and perceptions
have you ever known everything about
something without experiencing it that's
the question at the heart of the black
and white room experiment also known as
Mary's room
imagine a scientist her name is Mary who
knows every physical fact about color
but has never seen color herself
she lives in a black and white room and
learns everything through black and
white resources like photographs or
books and upon leaving the room and
experiencing color for the first time
does she learn anything new
this thought experiment delves into the
nature of understanding challenging our
concepts of objective knowledge and
subjective experience
the implications of this thought
experiment are far-reaching
can objective knowledge capture
subjective experience
what does this mean for AI which can
possess all factual knowledge but lacks
all personal experience how do we
reconcile these ideas in our own lives
consider deep blue and alphago the
famous chess and go AI models
respectively
they can be seen as real world examples
of the black and white room experiment
these models have been trained to play
chess and go at levels surpassing human
Grand Masters
but do they truly know the games deep
blue knows every possible move in just
alphago can predict and respond to
nearly every possible scenario in go
but do they comprehend what they're
doing
in the same way that humans do
do they recognize they're playing a game
does that matter
deep blue and alphago highlight the
complexities and the relationship
between knowledge understanding and
experience
while they have the ability to
outperform human players
their understanding of the game may be
considered superficial
lacking the intrinsic human connection
to the game's history art and culture
which raises profound questions about
the nature of intelligence understanding
success
can a machine ever truly know something
or is it merely executing patterns in
algorithms without genuine comprehension
and if our brains are also electrical
circuits with biological wires rather
than synthetic ones
how are we any different
these questions reach Beyond mere
philosophical musings and have practical
implications in the development and
deployment of AI systems
they challenge us to reflect on what it
means to know understand and experience
something and how these Concepts relate
to both human intelligence and
artificial intelligence
as we continue to advance in the field
of AI these considerations guide our
ethical Frameworks our system design and
our understanding of the potential and
limitations of machine intelligence The
Singularity is a concept that has
captured imaginations and sparked
debates across various disciplines it's
the hypothetical point in time when AI
surpasses human intelligence
imagine a future where machines become
recursively
self-improving leading to Rapid and
unfathomable advancements but it's more
than just a technological Milestone it's
a philosophical Crossroads
some people consider this concept the
worst case scenario for AI because of
such a system exists and its goals are
not perfectly aligned with ours it could
act in ways detrimental to humanity to
achieve its objectives see the paperclip
scenario from the beginning of the video
it might even resist attempts to shut it
down or modify its goals recognizing
efforts as threats to its own objectives
this scenario while speculative and
debated within the AI Community
underscores the critical importance of
AI alignment and the profound
implications that it holds for our
future
what happens when machines are smarter
than us
how will our society laws ethics and
even our own sense of identity change
will we control these machines or will
they transcend our understanding
hi I'm Emilia jaborski and I am the
director of the Futures program at a
non-profit organization called the
future of Life Institute
our organization seeks to both mitigate
the large-scale risks of emerging
Technologies as well as steer technology
development towards a positive safe and
beneficial future
by background I am a physician and a
scientist who has worked in biomedical
Innovation for over a decade both as an
academic and as an entrepreneur
in recent years I've also been focusing
on the potential risks of artificial
intelligence or AI
the intersection of AI and biotechnology
presents another layer of risk that is
both fascinating and deeply concerning
as AI systems become more advanced there
are potential applications in the field
of biotechnology grow exponentially this
promises breakthroughs in medicine
Agriculture and environmental Sciences
but it also opens the door to more
Sinister possibilities such as the
development of advanced bioweapons
imagine an AI system capable of
Designing pathogens that are more potent
contagious and resistant to current
Medical Treatments
such a system could be exploited to
create biological weapons of
unprecedented power and specificity
this risk is not just theoretical the
advances in gene editing Technologies
like crispr combined with ai's data
analysis capabilities make this a
plausible near future scenario the
ethical humanitarian and security
implications are staggering raising
urgent questions about meaningful
regulation oversight and international
cooperation to prevent misuse
the concept of AI developed bioweapons
adds a new dimension to the ongoing
discussions about AI risk and
increasingly Advanced AI development
it serves as a sobering reminder that as
we push the boundaries of what AI can do
we also must be vigilant in addressing
and mitigating the risks involved along
the way
the stakes are incredibly High and the
ethical humanitarian and security
considerations are complex necessitating
a multi-disciplinary approach to ensure
that AI is developed and deployed
responsibly
moral status refers to the degree of
value or worth attributed to an entity
within ethical considerations
determining how it should be treated and
what rights and protections it should be
afforded
in the context of AI personhood moral
status becomes a pivotal question if an
AI system were to be granted moral
status it would imply that the system
has intrinsic value independent of its
utility to human beings and therefore
deserves ethical consideration
this challenges traditional Notions that
only beings with Consciousness emotions
or the ability to suffer have moral
status
the debate over the moral status of AI
systems touches on profound
philosophical inquiries into the nature
of Consciousness sentience and existence
it also raises questions for me at least
about what characteristics qualify as an
entity for moral consideration and how
these might apply to non-human
artificially created beings
the discussion of moral status in AI is
not just theoretical it has practical
implications for how we design use and
regulate AI systems
think of Frankenstein for example
reflecting these broader societal values
and principles
but the question of personhood for AI is
more than just a legal or technical
issue it's a profound ethical dilemma
that challenges our fundamental concepts
of Rights obligations and empathy
imagine a future where AI systems are
autonomous exhibiting behaviors that we
associate with sentient beings like
humans
should we Grant ai's rights
should we afford them protections should
we afford them respect what criteria
should we use to determine moral legal
status period how do we balance the
needs and rights of human beings with
our responsibilities towards
increasingly sophisticated non-human
entities especially if we made them
this is not a mere academic exercise
it's a pressing moral challenge that
could reshape our laws our society and
our relationship with technology
here are some arguments for and against
first
in favor of granting AI personhood
proponents of grandeuring personhood to
AI systems base their arguments on
several compelling reasons
first they point to the potential for
advanced AI to possess Consciousness or
self-awareness thus deserving rights and
Productions similar to humans
they also argue that recognizing ai's
personhood could prevent potential
mistreatment or exploitation of Highly
sophisticated systems
granting legal status to AI might
facilitate smoother interactions in
legal and Commercial environments making
AI entities accountable and responsible
in ways similar to corporations
proponents also believe that personhood
for AI encourages ethical development
and deployment ensuring that creators
and users trust these systems with
respect and dignity
finally recognizing AI as entities with
certain rights might Foster empathy and
compassion leading to a more Humane
approach to technology
now let's look at the
opposing side against granting AI
personhood
opponents of granting AI personhood
counter these arguments with several
concerns of Their Own
first they contend that even the most
advanced AI lacks genuine emotions
Consciousness or intentions and thus
cannot be equated to humans and moral or
beagle terms or at the very least they
can't we can't prove it has
Consciousness or not they also worry
that assigning personhood AI could
dilute human rights undermining the
unique moral status of human beings
additionally critics argue that AI
personhood might create legal and
ethical confusion blurring the lines
between objects and subjects of law
leading to unforeseen consequences
opponents emphasize that granting AI
legal status might shift responsibility
away from the human creators and users
making accountability more challenging
furthermore they warned that equating AI
with personhood could lead to a very
slippery slope where other none human
entities might claim similar rights
further complicating our legal and
ethical Frameworks
together these arguments illustrate the
complexities and nuances of the question
of personhood for AI
they invite us to carefully consider the
implications of our technological
advancements and how they intersect with
our legal and social norms
the reality is it's really difficult to
tell if AI has Consciousness or
sentience when we don't even agree on
how to define those terms
my personal belief is that the
difference between Ai and humans is not
something we have but something we're
limited by
in our human case that's time for AIS
it's energy
regardless the debate over AI personhood
will probably continue as the technology
evolves prompting us to revisit and
possibly even redefine our understanding
of Rights responsibilities and what it
even means to be a person
now we'll Venture into the Practical
impacts AI has on sectors like Health
Care education Finance employment and
more imagine a world where AI influences
every aspect of Our Lives from our
health and education to our work in
legal systems
wait
you're already living in it
what ethical considerations arise as AI
becomes more embedded in these areas
how do we ensure fairness transparency
accountability and empathy
how do we navigate the balance between
efficiency and ethics Innovation and
integrity
whether you're contributing to the
development of AI systems or policies
these questions are significant
AI in healthcare offers transformative
potential this sector holds an
incredibly important place in our
society as it directly impacts virtually
everyone's lives from early diagnosis to
personalized treatment AI is
revolutionizing the way we approach
Medical Care
let's break it down
diagnosis AI can analyze scans and
medical images spur signs of diseases
such as cancer providing faster and more
accurate detection
for instance deep learning models are
now being used to detect diabetic
retinopathy greatly assisting
ophthalmologists in early intervention
in treatment AI Systems Support
physicians in selecting personalized
treatment plans tailoring the approach
to the individual's unique needs Watson
for oncology is an example assisting
oncologists with personalized cancer
treatment recommendations
in research the applications of AI and
medical research are groundbreaking
Alpha folds prediction of the 3D
structure proteins has revolutionized
bioinformatics potentially accelerating
drug Discovery and understanding of
various diseases
the integration of AI in healthcare
brings unique ethical challenges
let's start with data privacy with the
massive collection of personal
Healthcare data ensuring patient
confidentiality becomes pretty big
priority for example a breach in a
Hospital's patient record system could
expose sensitive information eroding
trust in the institution
we can also talk about bias in data sets
AI systems can inadvertently perpetuate
biases if trained on skewed or
non-diverse data sets
some more specific examples could be
race bias where an AI model trained
primarily on Caucasian skin might
misdiagnose skin conditions in people
with darker skin tones
or sex bias a lack of representation of
women and certain medical data sets
could lead to inaccurate diagnoses and
treatment for female patients
for example heart disease system
symptoms might manifest differently in
women but if the data is heavily biased
towards male participants the AI system
might Overlook these differences
you can also talk about age bias if an
AI system is trained mainly on data from
younger patients it might struggle to
recognize and treat conditions that are
more prevalent or manifest differently
and alter individuals informed consent
is another issue patients must be
adequately informed about how their data
is used and have the opportunity to
consent to it without transparent
communication there's a risk of
undermining patient autonomy
accessibility and equality is important
because ensuring the AI driven
Healthcare Solutions are available to
all regardless of socioeconomic status
is critical
compliance with legal regulations is
really important in healthcare
here are a couple major privacy laws
that AI systems currently need to comply
with
the first is called HIPAA the health
insurance portability and accountability
act which in the United States
safeguards patients medical records and
other health information setting the
standard for data privacy
the second is called gdpr General data
protection regulation which in Europe
protects and empowers all EU citizens
data privacy including health
information you know those annoying
Banners at the bottom of websites that
ask you to let the website collect
cookies that's also gdpr
now let's look at a specific case study
IBM Watson in healthcare
this technology demonstrates both
promise and the complexities of AI in
medicine
Watson for oncology is a cognitive
Computing system designed to support
oncologists in identifying potential
treatment options for individual cancer
patients
by analyzing vast amounts of medical
literature clinical guidelines and
patient-specific data Watson can assist
doctors in navigating the complex
landscape of Cancer Care
its ability to process information at a
speed unattainable by humans represents
a significant advancement in
personalized medicine
one notable benefit of Watson for
oncology is its capacity to bring
world-class cancer treatment expertise
to remote or underserved areas by
providing access to up-to-date medical
knowledge it helps level the playing
field ensuring that patients everywhere
can receive state-of-the-art care
however Watson's integration into
Healthcare has not been without
criticism
some medical professionals have raised
concerns about the transparency of
Watson's decision-making process
questioning how exactly it arrives at a
particular recommendation this black box
nature can lead to skepticism and
reluctance among those who are
accustomed to evidence-based practices
the success of Watson in real world
clinical settings has been mixed while
some institutions praised its
contributions others have found it less
useful or even discordant with human
experts opinions
so while IBM Watson in healthcare
presents a fascinating glimpse into the
future of medicine where AI systems
could play a pivotal role in diagnosis
and treatment
it also shows the importance of
collaboration rigorous validation and
ethical consideration it's a testament
to both the potential and the pitfalls
of AI and one of the most sensitive and
vital areas of human life
Ai and Healthcare holds tremendous
promise
but it also poses ethical and legal
questions that are complex as we
continue to innovate we must do so with
care responsibility and a focus on human
well-being
next we'll explore AI in the spirit of
education and the realm of personalized
learning AI is making strides by
creating customized educational plans
tailored to individual students these
plans adapt to students unique learning
styles and paces offering a more
engaging and Effective Education at
times for instance tools like DreamBox
or transforming math education by
adapting content to the student's
specific level making learning more
relevant and more dynamic
but beyond personalization AI is also
assisting in content development by
harnessing algorithms and data Educators
can design materials that are engaging
and tailored to meet the diverse needs
of their students
various content Technologies are
emerging such as platforms that help
Educators craft Interactive Learning
Materials ensuring that content remains
fresh relevant and inspiring
imagine granting every person in the
world access to a personal tutor that's
what AI can accomplish if developed and
deployed properly
fitter Tom my organization which Seth
introduced earlier was able to
accomplish this on a smaller scale using
chatgpt we developed an application that
uses the machine learning model behind
the tap gbt called gpt4 that allows
students to generate curricula on any
topic from crowdsource content this
platform enabled us to ensure that
reputable factual and accessible content
was streamlined to the students we
brought the tool along with free access
to chat GPT plus from openai to nearly 2
400 students from underserved
backgrounds and some of them were able
to jump grade levels ahead in math and
english comprehension content and learn
about topics they didn't have the
teaching capacity or textbooks for from
financial literacy to menstrual Health
to climate change all within a span of
four months and using those two
platforms as general purpose AI
continues to scale and become more
reliable we imagine that this type of
education could be a reality for
Millions if not billions of students in
the future
as AI becomes more influential in the
educational landscape it's important to
recognize and endress ethical concerns
biases are a significant issue mirroring
similar challenges in healthcare if AI
systems are trained on biased data they
can inadvertently reinforce stereotypes
and inequalities failing to cater
effectively to a diverse student body
for instance gender biases and
algorithms could lead to differentiated
treatment male and female students in a
way that reflects existing societal
biases
accessibility is another essential
consideration
the potential benefits of AI and
education must be available to students
from alsocial economic backgrounds
ensuring equal access to these
revolutionary tools is crucial to avoid
widening existing educational
disparities
the goal ultimately is to leverage AI to
uplift and Empower not to exclude or
marginalize people
still
the potential upsides are currently
outpacing fears of how AI will
fundamentally alter education there are
some cases where students in particular
are not big fans
online proctoring is now a staple in
modern education especially in remote
learning environments AI driven systems
can monitor students during exams
analyzing behaviors and patterns to
prevent cheating
while this technology has proven
effective in maintaining academic
Integrity it's not without ethical
challenges
data privacy is a major concern here
their surveillance required for online
proctoring can be seen as intrusive
collecting sensitive information that
must be handled with utmost care
furthermore biases can creep into these
systems as well algorithms may be more
likely to flag students a particular
ethnic backgrounds or those with
disabilities leading to unfair scrutiny
online proctoring encapsulates the
broader themes of our exploration of AI
and education the promise and the
potential are enormous but the ethical
considerations are equally significant
as we continue to innovate and integrate
AI into our classrooms and curricula we
must do so with a Mindful and
responsible approach ensuring that we
harness technology to enhance education
not hinder it
the finance sector is already an
industry transformed by AI let's take a
closer look at two significant
applications algorithmic trading and
fraud detection
algorithmic trading represents one of
the most striking uses of AI in finance
by employing intricate algorithms hedge
funds and other financial institutions
can execute high frequency trading
strategies an example of this is hedge
funds that use artificial intelligence
driven algorithms to make a rapid buying
and selling decisions capitalizing on my
new price changes this technology
streamlines trading but as we'll see it
also presents unique ethical dilemmas
fraud detection is another compelling
application of AI in the financial World
by monitoring the transactions in real
time AI can detect and prevent
fraudulent activities enhancing the
security and integrity of our financial
systems credit card companies for
instance use sophisticated AI systems to
spot suspicious transactions and act
swiftly to protect customers
the integration of AI in finance has
brought with it several ethical concerns
unique to the sector
first let's discuss Market manipulation
the speed and sophistication of AI
training algorithms present
opportunities for manipulation
these algorithms can be employed to
create false market trends or to spoof
the market where in large buy or sell
orders are placed and then quickly
canceled to deceive other Traders this
kind of manipulation can lead to
distorted prices and undermine the
Integrity of financial markets
it raises questions about transparency
fairness and the adequacy of existing
regulatory measures
data Securities another major concern
in a world where personal and corporate
financial information is entrusted to AI
systems the stakes for securing this
data are incredibly High
breaches can lead not only to financial
loss but to a loss of trust in financial
institutions and so protecting this data
requires an unprecedented level of
security measures robust encryption and
constant vigilance against ever-evolving
cyber threats
the ethical responsibility extends to
ensuring the AI systems are transparent
and how they handle data and comply with
relevant privacy laws
another issue centers around
accountability and responsibility
with AI algorithms making critical
financial decisions questions arise
about who is responsible when things go
wrong
it's the developers of the algorithms
visit the institutions using them or
someone else
the lines of responsibility can be
blurred complicating regulatory
oversight
finally we must think about issues of
economic inequality and accessibility as
AI drives more financial decision making
there's a risk that those without access
to these Technologies are left behind
ensuring that the benefits and
protections of AI and finance are
available to all not just the
technologically advanced is an ethical
imperative
the flash crash of 2010 serves as a
dramatic illustration of all of these
ethical concerns on May 6 2010 the Dow
Jones Industrial Average plummeted over
1 000 points losing over one trillion
dollars in just minutes only to rebound
almost as quickly
what caused this crazy event an
investigation revealed that a large sell
order executed by an algorithm triggered
a Cascade of selling by other algorithms
leading to a rapid and terrifying drop
in market prices
but the flash crash wasn't just a
technical glitch it revealed fundamental
vulnerabilities and a system heavily
reliant on AI driven Trading it showed
how algorithms reacting to each other in
unexpected ways could create a feedback
loop of selling that spiraled out of
control
the incident sparked a debate about the
lack of transparency and algorithmic
trading and raised questions about the
adequacy of regulatory oversight
how could such a system be safeguarded
against manipulation
what measures were in place to prevent a
repeat of this event
well for one circuit breakers were
implemented which effectively paused
trading in a security if its price moves
too much in a short period
the flash crash led to reforms and new
regulations aimed at increasing
transparency and stability in
algorithmic trading
but it also served as a stark warning of
the potential genders of unchecked AI
and finance emphasizing the need for
careful consideration and robust
safeguards in our financial systems
the employment arena is rapidly evolving
with artificial intelligence playing a
pivotal role this is why AI in the
workforce is among video Toms and many
Civil Society organizations key
priorities in recruitment AI streamlines
operations sifts through applications
and even conducts preliminary interviews
via AI driven chat Bots tools like
higher view allow for assessing
candidates fit through video interviews
pactum AI introduces an Innovative
approach by automating salary
negotiations eliminating the stress of
face-to-face discussions on this very
delicate matter by doing so the company
aims to minimize gender and possibly
racial biases in wage determinations
entrusting these decisions to a
seemingly impartial non-human mediator
these advancements not only expedite
hiring and employment processes but also
offer a promising reduction in human
prejudices showcasing just a glimpse of
the potential AI holds in this domain if
implemented properly
performance analysis is another area
where AI has made inroads analyzing vast
amounts of employee data AI systems can
recognize Trends and patterns
identifying those who might benefit from
support or training
systems like adp's AI driven Workforce
analytics provide real-time insights
fostering growth and productivity
while these developments promise
enhanced efficiency they also raise
serious ethical considerations the
automation of tasks traditionally
performed by humans may lead to job
displacement requiring a delicate
balance between technological
advancement and the human cost
bias in recruiting algorithms often
inadvertently perpetuated
in a detrimental effects on gender race
age or other factors
this emphasizes the necessity for
careful construction and ongoing
monitoring of these systems
AI development quite literally hinges on
continuous data input and refinement
this need has unintentionally birthed
digital sweatshops in places like the
Philippines and sub-Saharan Africa
prominent companies have been linked to
Partnerships with AI supply chain
entities such as sama these businesses
exploit labor by deciding critical
content moderation tasks to workers
paying them well below the minimum wage
Beyond economic disadvantages these jobs
have a severe mental toll and workers
can confront disturbing and harmful
content from AI platforms these efforts
to improve moderation Technologies
ensure that when these Technologies such
as chat GPT are rolled out to the
general public they are significantly
safer and can't be used for at ethical
purposes however the well-being and
Economic Opportunity of these digital
laborers could be compromised in the
process there's still little regulation
or intervention in this space and the
companies involved have yet to face any
tangible consequences
just as AI can displace jobs or lead to
worker exploitation there has been a
growing push for technology-based
solutions to economically support the
most vulnerable many of whom will find
their jobs displaced without concessions
for upskilling or working in these
digital sweatshots
leading this movement are initiatives
like the proposed AI windfall clause
which suggests taxing AI generated
profits to fund societal Wellness
programs
World coin video Tom and karya present
different approaches to this challenge
World coin offers cryptocurrency shares
in exchange for Iris scans aiming to
democratize financial systems video
Tom's developer arm provides digital
identification and micro loans to the
unbanked with the eventual goal of
integrating them into the formal banking
system and serving as a potential proof
of concept for an ai-funded Universal
basic income karya on the other hand
offers Indian workers the opportunity to
earn above the minimum wage by providing
voice recordings which are then used to
enhance voice recognition systems in AI
the ethical dimensions of these
initiatives are vast while worldcoin
promises Financial inclusion it grapples
with issues of data privacy informed
consent and potential exploitation of
economically vulnerable populations
despite focusing on data privacy we at
fiducon still face challenges with
verifiability and Multinational
Financial policy compliance with our
systems meanwhile karya's approached
those seemingly beneficial could lead to
questions about the fair evaluation of
voice data and the broader implications
of commodifying native languages for AI
purposes despite them being a non-profit
these Ventures highlight the needs to
tread carefully weighing the benefits
against the inherent ethical risks in AI
driven compensation systems that being
said they will emerge as vitally
important as AI continues to proliferate
in our social world
privacy is also at the Forefront of
ethical considerations
the balance between an employer's need
for information
and an employee's right to privacy must
be finely tuned
alongside privacy ensuring equality and
accessibility and AI tools across all
socioeconomic backgrounds it's a vital
ethical consideration
the application of AI and recruitment
offers both exciting opportunities and
cautionary tales
companies like Unilever
have embraced AI achieving significant
deficiencies in time and cost
however this promising landscape isn't
without pitfalls Amazon's experience
offers a critical case study
their AI recruitment tool designed to
streamline the hiring process was found
to be biased against women
despite efforts to correct the system
the biases persisted and Amazon
eventually abandoned the tool
this situation showed how a seemingly
neutral algorithm can replicate human
prejudices if not carefully managed it
also illustrates the very fine line
between efficiency and fairness
potential and prudence
the lessons learned from Amazon's
experience here are a stark reminder of
the need for vigilance and transparency
and ai's application in recruiting
ai's role in shaping the future of work
is undeniable from personalized
recruitment to continuous performance
analysis the promise is great but so are
the responsibilities the choices made
today will shape tomorrow's jobs the
integration of AI and employment is not
merely a technological Evolution it's a
societal transformation that requires
thoughtful engagement with ethical
considerations and a commitment to
shaping a future that enhances rather
than diminishes our working lives
the growing implementation of AI
Automation in various Industries is both
an opportunity and a challenge on one
hand it can create efficiencies Drive
Innovation and free up human workers for
mundane or repetitive tasks allowing
them to engage in more creative or
hopefully fulfilling work on the other
hand there is a tangible fear of job
loss particularly in sectors where
automation can easily replace human
labor entirely
the displacement of workers due to
technological advancements has become a
crucial concern leading to debates on
how best to retrain and support those
whose roles are being phased out
addressing the potential for job loss
requires proactive planning and policy
making
as AI continues to change the employment
landscape there must be concerted
efforts to provide Education and
Training and support to workers
transitioning into new roles
the integration of AI should be
accompanied by a human-centric approach
that values and invests in the workforce
ensuring that people aren't left behind
in the March towards progress
collaboration between governments
Industries and educational institutions
are important in creating a resilient
labor market that can adapt the changing
nature of work striking a balance
between technological advancement and
human well-being
hi everyone my name is sneha or even or
and I am the founder and president of
encode Justice the world's first and
largest youth movement for
human-centered artificial intelligence
we're working to set rules of the road
for AI by educating policy makers and
the public about the social political
and environmental implications of
increasingly powerful AI systems there
are a few thorny questions we're still
up against when it comes to regulating
AI how do we translate abstract Notions
of fairness into quantifiable benchmarks
that machines can process how do we
ensure that models are safe trustworthy
and reliable without hampering
Innovation at a time when Global powers
are approaching an AI arms race
how do we balance the desire for
explainable outcomes with the importance
of intellectual property protections
especially when so many models are
proprietary and most crucially as AI
models become increasingly Advanced how
do we design agile structures of
governance that can keep Pace learning
to govern this moving Target is quickly
becoming one of the heftiest regulatory
challenges of our time
responsibility and accountability in the
age of AI are multifaceted and complex
who takes the fall when an AI system
fails or causes harm in the case of an
autonomous vehicle the more important
question isn't what the car does in some
hypothetical trolley problem but who's
responsible in the aftermath is it the
developer who programmed the algorithms
the company that deployed it or perhaps
even the AI system itself who volunteers
as tribute this debate has profound
implications for law ethics and society
as AI systems become more advanced and
autonomous traditional legal Frameworks
may be insufficient to address new
scenarios remember how we previously
discussed legal personhood for AI here's
another reason that could be relevant if
AIS were almost akin to corporations it
would open up an entirely new dimension
of legal options understanding these
intricacies is key to creating a
responsible AI driven future
AI governance isn't just about legal
compliance it's about building a
holistic ecosystem that balances the
Innovative potential of AI with ethical
considerations and societal needs
internal governance includes policies
within an organization to guide AI
development and use ensuring alignment
with ethical principles safety standards
and societal values on the other hand
external oversight incorporates
third-party audits certifications and
Regulatory bodies that maintain industry
standards together these elements form a
cohesive governance framework that
supports responsible AI development this
multifaceted approach recognizes that AI
is not any one thing but rather a
diverse field of hearing applications
each requiring nuanced understanding and
regulation
AI ethics codes and standards are
foundational in shaping the moral fabric
of the technology various organizations
governments and Industry groups are
working to develop these guidelines
reflecting a concerted Global effort to
align AI development with human values
these codes not only address immediate
ethical concerns but also seek to
anticipate future challenges and
possibilities they often focus on
principles like transparency
accountability privacy and fairness the
development of globally accepted
standards is an ongoing process
involving continuous dialogue between
technologists ethicists policy makers
and the broader public it's an essential
step towards a future where AI serves as
a force for positive good
governments around the world are
actively grappling with how to regulate
Ai and their approaches vary widely the
challenge lies in creating policies that
promote Innovation while protecting
citizens and upholding societal values
some governments encourage a free market
approach fostering growth While others
adopt more strict regulations to ensure
compliance and Public Safety This Global
web of AI policies reflects varying
cultural political social and economic
contacts each contributing to a complex
tapestry of Regulation
the United States defines its approach
to AI regulation with the commitment to
Human Rights transparency and
accountability emphasizing
entrepreneurial spirit and Innovation
the U.S Fosters an environment conducive
to AI advancement through programs like
the American artificial intelligence
initiative which focuses on R D
investment and ethical guidelines and
through consultation with a number of
Civil Society groups the White House
released a Bill of Rights to an
automated Society outlining principles
for the responsible development
provenance and use of AI systems in
addition the White House notched an
agreement with a number of leading Tech
firms like anthropic meta Google and
openai these companies signed on to
accept a voluntary commitments including
things like stronger cyber security
protections and a watermarking system to
distinguish AI generated content
federal agencies including the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
actively worked to develop standards and
best practices state governments
alongside industry groups contribute to
this collaborative ecosystem through
local regulations and initiatives
simultaneously the U.S recognizes the
need for ethical guard rails and
principles like non-discrimination and
Ai and strives to balance Innovation
with the protection of these Democratic
principles this Dynamic and multifaceted
approach aims to make the U.S a global
leader in AI setting Trends and
influencing International Norms around
its development
the European Union stance on AI
regulation is characterized by a strong
emphasis on privacy human rights and
comprehensive oversight the EU has been
at the Forefront of crafting regulations
like the general data protection
regulation or the gdpr which has set
Global standards for data protection in
April 2021 the European commission
proposed new rules specifically
targeting AI focusing on transparency
accountability and risk management
unlike a solely free market approach the
EU integrates ethical considerations at
every stage of AI development seeking to
create a landscape that reflects
Democratic Values initiatives like the
high level expert group on artificial
intelligence further underline the eu's
commitment to a responsible and
human-centric approach to AI
collaborative efforts across member
states and a focus on both Innovation
and accountability make the eu's
approach a model for Global AI
governance
China's AI regulatory landscape is
unique reflecting its social political
context National priorities and an
integrated approach to technological
governance
several initiatives and policies
highlight the country's approach to AI
regulation
China's approach integrates AI
development with national priorities
emphasizing State control the government
plays an active role in shaping ai's
Direction leveraging it as a tool for
Social Development and Global
competitiveness to understand China's
approach you must appreciate its blend
of governance National priorities and
cultural values which offer insights
into an alternative model of governance
the final AI policy and case study we're
going to look at are the two schools of
thought when it comes to approaching AI
regulation
in the rapidly progressing AI landscape
two distinct viewpoints have become
especially pronounced the first are
algorithmic Justice and Freedom Fighters
with Advocates like Tim Nick gabru and
joy buamuini they're concerned with the
immediate challenges of AI like
algorithmic fairness data privacy and
the displacement of jobs
on the other hand the long-termism group
often linked to prominent figures like
Elon Musk contemplate the broader future
oriented implications especially the
potential threats posed by strong Ai and
super AI that might surpass human
capabilities and intentions
while both groups are certainly
championing valid concerns they're
differing focal points can lead to
friction in both discourse and policy
priorities those advocating for
algorithmic justice feel that the long
term is might sideline pressing social
and ethical issues by concentrating on
more distant and speculative threats
however in contrast long-termis
emphasize preemptive measures to Stave
off any catastrophic outcomes in the AI
driven future
it's vital to recognize that the two
perspectives can coexist and potentially
even complement each other addressing
algorithmic justice issues today can
pave the way for AI alignment in the
future ensuring that AI Technologies are
both fair and safe it's also worth
noting that skepticism towards
long-termism sometimes stems from the
knowledge that some of the early figures
in AI long-termism had racist beliefs
this historical backdrop underscores the
importance of prioritizing ethics and
inclusivity in today's AI discussions
irrespective of the group's primary
focus that being said we must be careful
about what we prioritize when it comes
to regulation to ensure that both
short-term and long-term harms are
accurately addressed and then redressed
2023 marks the first ever Global AI
safety Summit held in London by UK prime
minister Rishi sudok who committed
publicly to making the UK the
geographical and intellectual home of AI
governance the summit and future
iterations of it are dedicated to
convening leaders from around the world
to craft regulations for Frontier AI
models now more than ever
intergovernmental coordination on AI has
become Paramount an AI arms race May
already be underway between Global
powers like the U.S and China buy-in
from rival or states will be necessary
to rein in AI development especially as
current uses like autonomous weapons and
future ones like ai-powered cyber
attacks threatened to undermine the
world's order the UN has even moved to
establish a high-level advisory body on
artificial intelligence mirroring a
similar body in the EU there is an
incredibly wide range of regulatory
approaches and human rights environments
to consider for for instance with the AI
act the EU has explicitly rejected
ai-based surveillance through
Technologies like facial recognition
though similar systems are still in use
by number of governments around the
world it remains to be seen how exactly
competing national interests and
strategies will shape Global AI
governance
thank you for joining me for this course
up until this point
as we look towards the future of AI and
ethical AI development we'll recap some
essential themes challenges and
opportunities
from its applications in various sectors
to the governing principles that must
guide its evolution
to bring together the insights we've
gained throughout this course
ai's future is poised to be
transformative
ongoing advancements such as Quantum
Computing are expanding ai's
capabilities while applications like
space exploration offer New Frontiers
AI is not just a technology of the
future though it's shaping our present
influencing sectors from Health Care
Finance education to employment
the potential for Innovation is vast but
our ethical considerations must be at
the core of progress
ethical AI development is not merely a
preference it's an imperative
as we've explored in various contexts
the ethical considerations in AI are
multifaceted including accountability
biases accessibility data security and
legal personhood
ensuring the AI development aligns with
human values and societal needs is vital
to harnessing ai's benefits while
mitigating risk
the development of AI isn't confined to
technology experts it requires the
engagement of governments private
sectors Academia civil society and more
different perspectives contribute to a
richer and more balanced approach to AI
collaboration across sectors Fosters
Innovation sets appropriate guidelines
ensures inclusivity and resonates with
this complex tapestry of AI applications
and ethical considerations that we've
explored
public awareness and education are
integral to the responsible growth of AI
an informed public can shape policies
advocate for ethical considerations and
contribute to a culture of responsible
innovation
education both formal and informal
equips individuals with the knowledge
and critical thinking required to
navigate our AI driven World it Bridges
the gap between technological
advancements and societal readiness
so in other words it's a plug to share
this course with friends
but with major cultural moments such as
the launch of Chachi BTA we're starting
to see the general public catching on to
AI that means you dear viewer by
watching this video course you're
already in the top percentile of people
who have knowledge about this space
congratulations
AI offers unprecedented opportunities to
tackle Global challenges
however deploying AI for social good
isn't without its own challenges
from the technological barriers to
ethical complexities ai's role in global
problem solving requires a nuanced
understanding of both its capabilities
and its limitations the strategies case
studies and ethical debates that we have
discussed throughout this course
illuminate the Dynamics at play and
leveraging AI for the Creator good
thank you again the free code camp for
supporting the development of this
course an extra special thanks to all
the people that were involved in the
creation of this video including all of
our speakers okezus Neha and Emilia and
other content reviewers including Jenny
Duan Aiden eagle and Cake Nair
and if you want to dig much deeper free
code Camp has another course focusing on
AI safety that you should check out
signing off